Straight Ahead online grind daily with
Sandy Hook defamation trial after the
shock of of Ben's murder
we were
I mean the best way to describe it is we
were like I felt like I was underwater
emotional testimony from the families
soon
ER comments he made after the 2012 Sandy
Hook shooting plus the defense begins
presenting its case in the trial of Paul
and Ruben Flores 26 years after The
Disappearance of Kristen smart and
ex-minnesota cop Thomas Lane faces a
judge for a sentencing on state charges
over his role in the 2020 Death of
George Floyd then later the trial of
George Wagner IV could you see the
condition of those bodies in the
condition of the bed
yes and was that a
pretty bloody scene it was an Ohio jury
hears testimony about a second crime
scene where two members of the rodent
family were murdered long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and con Daly I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer Connecticut
jurors here powerful testimony for the
parents of the victims of the 2012 Sandy
Hook shooting at several families Sue
Infowars hosts and conspiracy theorists
Alex Jones this comes as part of one of
three defamation trials against Jones 15
plaintiffs filed lawsuits against him
after he told his Infowars audience that
the school shooting was a hoax put on by
crisis actors to push gun control the
plaintiffs made up of family members of
eight of the students and staff killed
and an FBI agent say Jones's followers
have harassed them and even made death
threats Jones has already been found
liable for damages in this case meaning
jurors will only decide how much Jones
should pay the families Jones is
expected to take the stand at some point
in the case on Wednesday morning jurors
heard from David wheeler the father of
Benjamin wheeler a six-year-old who was
killed at the Sandy Hook Elementary
School he got emotional as he testified
about a memory he has of his son then he
was asked about what things were like
after the shooting
after the shock of of Ben's murder
we were
I mean the best way to describe it is we
were like I felt like I was underwater
and I didn't know I didn't know which
way was up
and so
you're
you're grasping with that you're trying
to get your head around that
and
to have
someone
publicly
tell you telling the world that it
didn't happen
and that you're a fraud and a phony
uh is incredibly disorienting
it's like
you're already fighting
and I could not understand why in the
world anyone would think this
I I couldn't figure it out
at the lunch recess Jones held a press
conference outside the courthouse
telling reporters he's apologized dozens
of times for his comments
I have apologized for six years
for anything that I did wrong
questioning Sandy Hook I didn't question
Sandy Hook to be mean I wasn't the
leader of questioning Sandy Hook but I
did say things that were hurtful and not
true but I did not do it on purpose I
have a right
I have a right to question something now
if that becomes hurtful of individuals
and causes them pain that is certainly a
problem and I have admitted to that so
that's where we stand they are using
this case to go after the first
amendment Sandy Hook has been used to go
after the Second Amendment and the right
to keep bear arms now it's being used to
go after
the first amendment I will not perjure
myself I didn't pre-meditatively uh
question uh Sandy Hook I I question
everything
joining us today is former SWAT in
Chicago area detective Lisa Lockwood and
co-host Terry Austin Lisa everyone is
awaiting Jones's testimony but do you
think anything he says on the stand can
reduce how much he will owe these
families
if we're using Texas as an example where
he got hit with nearly a 50 million
dollar payout I would say no what is he
going to do differently I'm sure his
attorneys are going to try and reel him
in to have him show some more remorse in
all of this but I think just him going
outside the courtroom and pontificating
and saying how much he apologized in the
last six years well guess what this
happened 10 years ago so that means four
years he was out there still
perpetuating the falsehood and I think
they have enough evidence right now to
show that once he knew he did not dial
back once he knew he allegedly knew it
was not a hoax he never dialed back and
the money continued to come in so I
don't see anything that he's going to
say right now that's going to help him
regarding his damages yeah Terry Lisa
brings up a good point looking at the
Texas case because in the Texas case he
did owe about 50 million dollars in
Connecticut he's being sued by multiple
families each with their own losses
we're hearing from these family members
so is it fair to assume that he maybe
that they may be awarded I don't know
like a hundred million dollars in
Damages in this case
well I expect that we're going to see a
very large number at least that large
and it could be even you know multiples
of that you know you have the families
of at least four children a couple of
Educators one first responder and they
were all harassed and threatened to
varying degrees the verdict form is
going to include the names of all of
those families and it's going to have a
place for them to fill in the amount and
it really does depend on how much they
have suffered and you heard David
wheeler in the stand today one of the
parents and I do believe that he'll get
one of the larger Awards because he was
threatened he was one of the former
actors that was targeted yeah I would
agree with you there we'll keep eyes on
this case as it develops and in New York
following a three-year investigation New
York attorney general Leticia James
announces a 250 million dollar civil
suit against former president Donald
Trump his adult children and the Trump
Organization for what the state is
calling a large-scale business fraud
James alleges in the new lawsuit that
the Trump's grossly inflated the former
president's net worth by billions of
dollars she says they cheated lenders
and others with a false and misleading
financial statements the suit also
alleges more than 200 instances of fraud
over a 10-year period the suit also
seeks to prohibit any of the trumps from
leading a company in the state of New
York at a press conference Wednesday
morning James said the former
president's conduct cannot be brushed
aside and dismissed as some sort of
honest mistake
this investigation revealed that Donald
Trump engaged in years of illegal
conduct to inflate his net worth
to achieve to deceive Banks
and the people of the great state of New
York
claiming you have money that you do not
have
does not amount to the art of the deal
it's the art of the steel
and there cannot be different rules for
different people in this country or in
this state
and former presidents are no different
and so today we are making good
on that promise
on our commitment
because no one
no one
is above the law
CNN reports former president and Trump
responded to Wednesday's announcement
saying quote today's following is
neither focused on the facts nor the law
rather it is solely focused on advancing
the Attorney General's political agenda
it is abundantly clear that the Attorney
General's office has exceeded its
statutory Authority by prying into
transactions where absolutely no
wrongdoing has taken place
a suspect is in custody in Washington
D.C after allegedly vandalizing the
Washington Monument with red paint Crews
began cleaning up the paint early
Wednesday morning just hours after the
incident late Tuesday night U.S part
police say the treatment to clean the
134 year old structure could take weeks
and needed to happen immediately because
the poorest surface of the marble 44
year old Sean Ray dean of Indiana was
arrested and charged shortly after the
incident he is charged with the
trespassing tampering and vandalism and
could face additional charges an
investigation is ongoing
still had on Law and crime daily one of
the ex-officers charged in the death of
George Floyd learns his fate the
sentence following a guilty plea to his
State charges
but first the state rests his case in
the trial of Paul and Reuben for us as
the father is on our tribe for the 1996
disappearance and murder of Kristen
smart
[Music]
moment
welcome back the prosecution rested his
case and the defense began calling
Witnesses Wednesday in the California
trial of Paul and Ruben Flores a father
and son charge in The Disappearance and
death of Kristen smart more than 25
years ago the Cal Poly student went
missing after a party in May of 1996.
Paul and Reuben were long as expected in
her disappearance but were arrested just
last year Paul is charged with Smart's
murder his father Reuben is charged with
accessory after the fact for allegedly
helping to hide the body by burying her
in his backyard and later moving her
Remains the case moved on to the defense
calling its first witness Wednesday
after their motion for a mistrial on
Tuesday was denied by the judge Paul's
attorney argued there is no evidence
linking his client to Kristen's murder
he apologized to Smart's family before
implying Kristen could be in another
country and not even dead the defense's
first witness called Wednesday is an
expert in human decomposition the trial
is expected to last through next month
Terry what was your takeaway from the
fireworks that flew at the end of the
prosecution's case who came out on top
the defense or prosecution
well I think the prosecution came out on
top I think both sides made some points
basically the defense was trying to
argue for this motion for dismissal when
we knew that wasn't going to happen
that's something that I think most
defense attorneys are going to do no
matter what and this is a case where
there's no body so there's some chance
that it could have prevailed but at the
end of the day I think the prosecution
ended up on top they ended up getting in
evidence that they wanted to get in that
the defense thought was inflammatory
having to do with sex toys that were
photographed and so I do think that that
jury is going to be at this point citing
in favor of the prosecution yeah now
Lisa after the prosecution's case were
you left with any questions of floors of
the floors is guilt that the defense May
argue in their case
I well my thought on all of this is how
did they bring the case forward and I
have a different opinion than Terry in
that he just because he was the last
person with her the fact that he had a
black eye is circumstantial it took him
all the way until 2011 to actually get
some pieces of what they thought was
evidence 18 search warrants came later
then accusations of rape from Paul from
two other women that came forward and
things were just not substantiated so
um having the alerts of two cadaver dogs
that the state put forward none of that
was able to prove any DNA who don't have
a body we cannot prove a rape so I think
it's going to still be very hard for the
jury to come to a guilty verdict all
right we'll see what the defense puts on
and of course it's still up to
summations those last and final
arguments from either side will keep
eyes on this the California view Paul
and Reuben Flores case and switching to
Texas where Houston Police released
dramatic body cam footage of a hosta
situation that led to an officer
shooting and killing the suspect it
happened last month in Splendora Texas
police say it All Began Monday August
22nd when 52 year old Melvin Porter held
his ex-girlfriend hostage at gunpoint
she got away but the next day officials
say Porter showed up at her work then
kidnapped and held one of her co-workers
at gunpoint Porter's ex-girlfriend
reportedly made a deal with him to
exchange herself for her co-worker the
ex-girlfriend got Porter to pull into a
gas station of officers surrounded the
car and what happened next was all
caught on camera
come here come here come here hey hey
hey come here come here come here come
here come here come here come here come
on come here come here come here come
here
come here okay you're okay you're all
right thank you okay thank you thank you
thank you thank you we're okay you all
right you all right you're okay thank
you you're okay you're okay you're okay
officers fatally shot Porter when they
say he was reaching for what they
believed was a weapon police did not
release the woman's identity
coming up on Law and crime daily the
Pike County Massacre jurors here at
testimony about processing another crime
scene after eight members of One family
were murdered in their vets plus a
former Minneapolis Police Officer is
sentenced for his role in The Death of
George Floyd will he get more prison
time at the state level
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily we head
now to Ohio for the trial of defendant
George Wagner IV where testimony ships
to a second crime scene where two of the
eight victims were killed in the Pike
County Massacre Wagner his brother Jacob
and their parents Angela and Billy are
charged with murdering eight members of
the rodent and Gilly families in April
of 2016. prosecutors say the shooting
deaths came amid a custody of his
dispute involving a young child Jacob
Wagner shared with Hannah May Rhoden the
victims were found dead in their homes
most were shot as they slept a George
argues he's not guilty because he didn't
actually pull the trigger jurors are
hearing about the murders one crime
scene at a time Wednesday Bureau of
Criminal investigations agent Todd
Fortner resumed testifying he was part
of the team which processed the crime
scene where Frankie Roden and Hannah
Hazel Gilly were killed he described the
scene as the jury was shown graphic
photos
when you beat your head in when you
looked in that room could you see the
bodies in the bed yes and could you
could could you see the condition of
those bodies in the condition of the bed
yes and was that a
pretty bloody scene it was
this is a photograph of
um Frankie and Hannah laying in bed they
appear to have gunshot wounds to the
Head
no other obvious wounds
on their torso or or any defensive type
wounds
um also
a great deal of blood between them where
the family indicates the infant was
laying did you also notice like smudging
and smearing of blood on their body
yes these are swipes and wipes on
Hannah's body that indicate movement
and it was would be consistent with an
infant laying between them moving
Lisa we're hearing the culmination of
this investigation while he's testified
I understand but especially with your
back room can you break down what went
into getting this information to us
through this testimony
right so obviously the person who's on
the crime scene the detective who's
initially investigating it you're going
to do a peripheral look before you
actually go inside and start collecting
evidence there's some photographs that
take place first there's audio
recordings
Etc and then to start to go forward but
the thing that I found interesting about
this not interesting I should say but
tragic is the fact that the live baby
was left there flailing for itself and
becoming engaged with the mother's blood
from the from the head wounds and uh
it's it's very hard and this this
officer was extremely professional in
his testimony absolutely now Terry is
there some sort of trick to presenting a
case with multiple victims in multiple
locations or is it just throw everything
at the jury and hope that it sticks well
the trick is to stay organized from the
very beginning of the case as far as the
prosecution is concerned I think the
defense probably wants to confuse the
jury and isn't going to be as organized
but I do think that because there are
eight victims and four defendants and
all of those individuals have extended
family members there should be an
organizational chart with pictures
actually of all of them so that the jury
can follow and they don't have to
question and because there are four
crime scenes I definitely think that
there should also be something
demonstrative it helps the jury to
follow along when they can see in scene
one this is the address this is who was
killed these are the bullets this is the
gun that was used these are the two guns
that were used so I definitely think
that you have to keep track of all of
the facts and you have to make it easy
for that jury to follow along and then
the last thing you have to go in
chronological order and I think the
prosecution did do that I think it's
going to be a very robust closing
Arguments for both sides I can see that
come coming well thank you Terry and
Lisa and thank you for joining us here
on Law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]